most NBA owners are concerned about
stats like points and rebounds but Los
Angeles Clippers owner Steve bombers
newest project tackles numbers far
beyond the basketball court the former
Microsoft CEO today is launching us a
fax a comprehensive database for
information about government it combines
federal state and local data from more
than 50 government sources the database
provides an in-depth look at the
American population government finances
and the government's impact on society
Steve Ballmer returns to studio 57 to
discuss this first-of-its-kind project
welcome thanks Nora pleasure to be here
I mean this is a massive endeavor why
did you commit to do this well I got
interested in in the context of learning
about you know the way government serves
kids who grow up in disadvantaged
situation and it was hard to find the
numbers i was looking for and I thought
geez if it was a company I'd look for
the 10k right and it couldn't find
anything like that now government's not
a business its measured on its impact
not on its P&L and I said look it's not
just about finances it's also about
impact the 10k format made sense to me
my curiosity took over and eventually it
seemed to make sense to share with
others yeah I know a lot of people very
rich people who will say to me you know
if I knew exactly where the money was
spent I'd be happy to pay more taxes
just I don't know how to find out where
the money goes well it takes a little
bit of work and there's more work to be
done I won't pretend we've got
everything solved there's more and more
data that we like to add more currency
to the data but you want to know about
spending charlie no I would say a nice
little picture here that you know sort
of straighten things out what's an
example of what you uncovered in all
this data yeah yeah yeah I mean look you
want that you want to look at the spin
right there now right the revenue
they're suspending that you but why was
it important to you see because you said
it's not about politics this is just
about giving people the facts ma'am
nothing but the facts like they used to
say on dragnet so what were some of the
things that surprised you and why did
you want to make sure that we all knew
what the facts were most important thing
that
surprised me is how hard it was to find
this stuff in any digestible form you
know you do searches you'll find various
things but if you wanted to like gems
the government employees 20 3.2 million
people I wouldn't have known that the
largest segment of sort of work in the
government teachers professors and
people who work around schools almost
half of all government employees
basically are in the education system
that felt good to me as an example you
know fires it's a silly one it's a small
one but the number of fires over the
last 37 years because we go back to
nineteen eighty where we can the number
of fires is down thirty or forty percent
while the populations grown forty
percent that's great what did you find
out about guns we have a lot we know
about how many guns are made we have a
lot because we only use government data
license made but the actual estimates of
gun ownership government's not allowed
to participate in that under law y-yeah
one would presume that there was work
done you know kind of I didn't
encouraging that with the legislation
with the Congress how much money goes to
non-governmental organizations people
who are doing philanthropic work it's
interesting officially none on the other
hand if you take a look particularly at
the money that goes into aid what we
call aid to the disadvantaged a lot of
that money gets essentially contracted
out to not-for-profits sometimes your
community health clinics sometimes it
would be you know certain organization
running a head start program providing
community services that provide social
and emotional health services which is a
big issue amongst disadvantaged kids
this is entirely nonpartisan entirely
nonpartisan the numbers are the numbers
that one thing about numbers that makes
them better than adjectives adjectives
can get partisan yeah numbers can't get
partisan yeah huge small yes well one
number might be 10 and the others 11
yeah but you can call those huge change
all if you want to how did you decide
what facts you were going to put in your
book what we did is we started with the
structure of the Constitution the
preamble the Constitution lays out the
missions of government and then we
developed structure for submissions if
you will and then we started pouring
numbers in there will be more things we
want to add but we had two goals we
wanted to be comprehensive we want to
have great context because looking at
numbers out of context you know without
any history without any related numbers
is tough but we still want to be
comprehensible so we wanted to have a
structure and let people then drill in
as deep as they want to I got to ask the
question earlier today what does it cost
to run the National Park System it is
not in our database on the other hand we
can tell you how many acres of land are
in the National Park System or managed
by the National Forest Service we have
that will continue to extend the
database didn't your lovely wife Connie
play a role in that she's with you today
in the green room because didn't you
wake up after Microsoft going what am I
going to do with my life and she said
philanthropy and you were like in that
how that happened mr. I was pretty tired
after I retired I thought I can't I'll
play a lot of golf and she said no no
you're gonna you're going to pitch in
here on our philanthropic and civic
stuff because in a sense at least in the
social service area philanthropy only
goes so far since most not-for-profits
in that in this area are funded by
government funds at least in part and
she pushed me on it I send you a
combined with pay our taxes that's the
best way to take care of the poor the
young the old because if we don't
believe in our government that's a
bigger problem actually than anything we
can do philanthropically so I started to
look at these topics and decided not
only do you need to have a view of what
government does do in this area but what
does government do with the rest of its
money what would it mean to increase
taxes or decrease taxes because any
program that you care about at least in
my view you look at it as a whole just
like you do in business you don't say
we're going to fund this and fund this
and fund this you got to actually have
some sensible budget Steve Game two well
tonight Oh game to let me do one quick
question about Microsoft you are now I
understand it the largest stockholder in
Microsoft yeah I'm I don't have to
disclose my holdings there may be a
mutual fund or two I think Charlie that
are bigger
yeah individual yeah largest invit what
influence are you having on the company
well you know I'm largely focused
elsewhere although whenever in the USA
facts product creation we're using Azure
we're trying to figure out how to use
some of the Microsoft visualization
tools so I'll shoot a little feedback
back to Microsoft on various product
questions and topics and we're talking a
little bit about the future of
entertainment I bring you the context of
basketball but where does virtual
reality augmented reality fit in so
we're doing you know doing some work and
I love talking about what exists either
fun game to do because they said we
gotta go okay quick I just want to know
about game two because you're going to
be courtside tonight half the fun of
going to a Clippers game which we've
been to is watching used you ever said I
think you ever say you know I'm just
gonna sit here quietly and just enjoy
the game I cannot sit there quietly
enjoy the item enjoyed the gas but not
quietly and actually I get graded off in
time do you yeah DeAndre Jordan comes up
to me occasionally after game and said
you you weren't there tonight you didn't
bring your game I've heard that be at
least one of our guys every time I've
seen an a-plus-plus have included
tippers yes yeah the Clippers plankton
we got the jazz second round of a second
game of our playoff series we got a lot
of work to do tonight we if we play fast
and we play with the right spirit we're
gonna win this puppy tonight go Chris
Paul yeah go Clippers we believe Steve
we believe the facts are back for coming
thank you thank you very much for
joining us at the table